I am a very curious person I'm
interested in people so I get to meet
lots of people stay in touch with a lot
of people
more about the world every company that
you know I work with is a world
so that's one aspect it has a lot of
problem solving potential right like a
lot of like small things that you need
to be attentive to and figure out then
how
and you need to be resourceful working
on it and there's the the hunt right
like there's there's drama there's uh
there's that uh there is building
relationship with wealth of people
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
foreign
to a very very special episode of 20
minute leaders today I'm with the
phenomenal effort the gun she is an HR
wizard with years upon years of
experience working with some of the most
amazing companies in the world and she's
an amazing friend for many years and
I've been learning a lot from her
um pretty much every day and especially
now as I dove myself into the world of
Entrepreneurship in a more professional
capacity and and she's been just
supremely helpful and Monumental and
building our team and the lessons that
she's been teaching me and so I'm very
very excited to welcome here today
A founder of work around strategic
Talent acquisition services
she can pretty much help figure out
growth pains she's let Google Israel's
Staffing for about a decade from the
Inception of the r d offices in Israel
in 2006 and managed the recruitment of
six Google offices in Europe including
Israel Russia northern Europe and ways
she has been with Google for 12 years
and in her last role at Google she was a
global recruitment manager at the
headquarters in California and then
headed the town team globally at the
Lyft autonomous driving Division and at
next Insurance she was selected as one
of the most prominent Human Resources
Professionals in Israel in 2014 and she
lectures blogs about the future of world
of work and she mentors entrepreneurs
and individuals which are involved in
the field
welcome again to 20 minute leaders death
it's been a few years it's been almost
three years and you were 100 years
pretty interesting we had a pandemic in
the middle we had a pandemic in the
middle
and we had multiple we moved into
incontinence both of us both of us smoke
the whole world shifted back and forth
hybrid in office a recession yeah a high
Everything feels like the last year is
represented three decades yeah and a lot
of it
sort of consolidates into some you know
the the very essence of of what we do
which is
you know where we spend our time and the
teams that we choose to align ourselves
with the problems that we tackle you
have many years of experience building
phenomenal teams and we're having work
that sound the most
um
amazing companies in the world not just
from a business perspective but from a
you know human perspective would you go
into the offices and just to name a few
Google Lyft next insurance and I have
the unique pleasure of having your
guidance in what we do I think and it's
like my pleasure hopefully one day we'll
be We'll add ourselves as a as it is
Mother Love of the list but but what I
want to focus on today in our
conversation is sort of the art of
building great teams because I'm
watching you interview and through our
conversations you're helping guide us on
the complexity and this puzzle of
identifying the right team members for
the right situations at the right times
and I want to unfold a little bit this
this puzzle and uh and so you know let's
start with you know what are the things
that you are now you know looking back
when you're approaching a situation
what questions are you even asking
about a a human resource situation
okay
so so you're saying just give me a
little bit more detail so I'm
approaching a team who wants to grow or
wants to add members and how do I guide
them through situation even what are the
questions if I were to ask you if I need
some help I want to build an amazing
team I I actually spent yesterday with a
team of uh in with a team of a group
that's working on uh something around
that she knows
and remind which company whatever and
they came to me with the notion that
they felt that they need some help
around building the tea because they
they felt that they weren't making the
right hires
uh so what we spent on doing I think
it's just a great example we'll spend
time doing was
first of all I think one of the most
important thing that is often
disregarded or missed is just getting
from what alignment
so often people who are actually working
on
hiring have an idea of what they're
looking for but they don't spend enough
time mauling over it and discussing it
and reaching some sort of a consensus
that will help them make a decision so
each one of them has an idea what
they're looking for but they don't have
the same views and using that kind of
you know the actually the uh using the
disparities between them to actually
understand what makes sense it's a good
discussion that typically uh moves the
thing forward so what I spend time with
them doing for example was we discussed
the profiles uh of who they want to hire
and this is sometimes into at least a
startup of about 20 people we spent some
time talking about it
um
because they were already doing the job
in hiring
but they realized first of all we talked
about Ruth who was the person that
they're looking for you know what skills
do they need
to often companies just copy paste job
descriptions the Clinton what else put
together and just thinking about that
really LGBT to make one for the exactly
which works great but you need to
actually you know have a discussion over
it and make sure that it represents your
own needs so we had a discussion over
that that we really asked you know what
would this person need to achieve and
what's missing today is eventually we
came together to some sort of an
understanding of what we're looking for
and then what we spent time over doing
is like looking at their current hiring
process and figuring it out if the uh
the weights that exist today the methods
that they are using to check are
actually achieving the goal
um
and we actually uh came to realize that
there were some discrepancies and
mistakes in the hiring process okay
not when whomever was hiring you know
spend time hiring and not in the actual
process of you know who's who's
interviewing what
uh first or next or whatever just in
Reading making sure that everything is
aligned that you know that they're using
the right methods to figure out that
there's enough information coming out of
the profit so that's one thing I ask
questions about you know what do you
want to hire why do you want to iron
this person what is this person is going
to do how are they going to fit the
whole you know the whole organizational
structure not to overstep someone else
how to make sure that there it works
together do they have they spent enough
time thinking about you know the
diversity of the talent in more ways
than one not just gender diversity
um do are they thinking about the
trajectory of the talent where's the
spirit this person you know comes on to
the team tomorrow how will they grow
will they have room to grow how will
they develop themselves uh
do they have somewhere to stretch
themselves or are they going to feel
bored next they didn't join the company
Etc what's missing in the current down
mix right perhaps you've hire a lot of
people that are the same profile you
don't have someone with the skills that
you're in for the future
stuck like that
it's an interesting conversation a lot
of times people don't just stop they
think about it more in a functional way
you know or what I gotta hire just a job
so it's very fat right you said a word
um that I want to add delay on just a
bit the word consistency yeah and then
you said there's something super
important so let's dive into it because
anyway then you close the loop with the
word discrepancy and right so they go
hand in hand let's let's talk a little
bit about this this question of
consistency amongst a team that is
looking to onboard yeah a new person to
their team
okay
consistency is important it's especially
important at scale
but even beforehand
um
say you were you you're going to
interview someone who's super talented
and you have your high rate bosses and
each person knows that they have their
interview questions they're going to ask
it but you don't have alignment you're
not sure what you're covering
what happens many many times and
actually I was in an event yesterday
evening in Google campus
and people were complaining about the
fact that they're being dragged
over and over
uh so come with this VP comment another
person another person in the hiring
process starts you know to kind of like
get inflated with many many interviews
in the hiring processing scene endless
and one of the reasons is because it
lacks consistency because no one sat and
thought what am I trying to figure out
here what data do I need how am I going
to get that data and make sure that
there is you know you have coverage of
everything and you haven't left anything
out
that consists that when you have that
you can reach some sort of a consistency
also
you can actually make sure that the bar
that you're testing people against is
similar if you're hiring for the same
role that allows you some agility in the
future you can move people between teams
Etc if you don't have consistency you
might be missing on you might be missing
out on great talent because you're
making decisions that are probably not
great if you are very simple because it
everyone asks whatever it comes to their
mind
you might be you know hiring okay
interviews are not a super
um
you know scientifically they are not a
proven way of you know a hiring like
they have a lot of problems but in order
to make them work you need that consist
you know that secret factor of
consistency to make sure the decisions
are sound even when they are a small
thing just sitting together having that
discussion of what you're looking for I
never really did that together well and
I think it really helped us you know
make better 100 the way that I have the
way that I'm looking now at it and the
complexity of the hiring process there
it isn't from how I looked at it three
months ago and I that leads to my next
question how do how if you weren't here
to tell me that the way that I'm going
through the hiring process I'm lacking
consistency and I'm lacking sort of this
under this understanding of a mentals
right how would I know how does you
would learn from the hardware indoor
okay making half a year or whatever so
what are the Pains of not having you
know a sound hiring process hiring the
state which are super expensive
and then why are they so expensive why
why because because you okay one thing
is that you know the time this person
worked probably
as you know it just it just went to the
trash right but more importantly Mystic
expectations you frustrate the person
you frustrate because that that's that's
not a nice or comfortable thing to have
like you know having to let people go
time that was lost energy a new product
that is going to suffer because you
haven't reached the goals that you're
looking for perhaps problems on the you
know more wider team it's it has so much
damage terrible yeah I mean it almost
feels like there's sort of the
instrumental piece of it where you're
missing out on the advancement of the
company the product here but the other
is dying but then there's a whole
culture issue right as by the time you
realize that this is a wrong hire or a
wrong match yeah at that point I guess
the ripple effect of this and the by the
time it gets to you as a CEO write it he
was quite a way you can it was a part of
the uh of the damage couldn't be that
you might use some great talent because
you've hired someone
what's going to happen like this this
company has some people that you know I
don't think should be here yeah and it's
also very it's wrong doing to the person
who's with hired to do the job you know
struggling at the job that's not great
like yeah you come out really you use
you know self-esteem Etc
so there are methodologies
to to help promote consistency right
because I think that coming into my
position three months ago I looked at it
and said great we'll have a job
description we'll get a committee you
you asked how do you know so if you have
if you find yourself evicted to
interviews over and over again or add
interviews or you feel that you do not
you you are finding it hard to make
decisions you don't have enough data or
the people that you that you bring or
learn about the right people or you're
finding it hard to attract people to
your company it's probably just because
you haven't
really thought out
everything about the hiring process and
it doesn't take a lot of time it just
means some you know opposite energy and
anyone can do it frankly it just takes a
simple conversation but most people
that's interesting most people
uh think that they know how to interview
which is probably not true I thought I
knew I I have no idea yeah I mean most
people think it just takes a
conversation
um and Truth is it's not about your
personality or experience it just you
just need some uh skills it's a skill
you can learn it right
but you know you can interview
uh in uh not in the correct way for
years and you wouldn't know
I remember at Google they had this sound
they had this uh research done
and they figured out that the years that
someone spent interviewing doesn't have
anything to do with the accuracy
there's no similar to you know there's a
matter of similar to different things
you know like spending some time on and
getting feedback learning how to do it
will helps but you know just actually
doing it for years without getting
feedback or correcting yourself you can
continue doing the same things and a lot
of a lot of companies they would use the
most senior person on the team as you
know the The Authority or an interview
like if you're the CEO you know maybe
you always did the Civil Right you make
the calls but actually the seal Could
lack interviewed skills just like anyone
else
yeah it sounds like there's there are
these um what you mentioned there are
those the sort of this accumulative
assumption that the higher that you go
in the range so the more years you spend
in in the whatever industry the more
capable you are of interviewing but yeah
it sounds like there are some
fundamental skills that need that means
some attention right that you know you
can learn but it but you need somebody
to guide you through that learning now
another way that I mode that the
company's map doing well
is um
is by looking at their interviewing data
when I look at the funnels I I like uh I
like Dr pipeline I look at funnels I see
where things get stuck or where the
hiring processes are working and
oftentimes it's because the interviewing
skills might be either you know missing
or just misaligned
and lots and and what it means in the
reward is it can be you know that you're
not hiring whoever you're looking for
but it also can be the fact that you're
spending so much energy until you're
finding that person which is
interviewable tons and tons spending
hours but not finding your personal just
because you're you lack skills or you
know in your hiring process is broken
yeah and I'm seeing it every time like I
I spend time talking to this uh
engineering manager a few weeks ago and
he was becoming impatient with the
candidates because he was doing
so many interviews eventually finding
you know talent to hire would spending
so much time on it
and it could be solved if there is focus
on it but a lot of companies do not
actually track anything you know or or
have like the system overview of the
hiring bus they just did it you know
they opened a position trying to feel it
just do they add them with the round two
there's no you know system oversight
yeah
you are a Matchmaker does the while your
expertise is in helping organizations
build amazing teams and you are also
very much aware of the candidate's point
of view and you're very sensitive to it
as well and I think that's also what
makes you so good at what you do
what is sort of this experience from the
candidate's perspective that managers
should be aware of so we talked and told
them about how do we make the best
process for us as sort of the hiring in
a way consistency also not scanted it
because they come to a hiring house
that's more solid more uh so what did
you find that candidates needed to have
a good experience they needed they need
clarity
they need uh ex they need to have set
expectations they need to know whether
where are they going to go through how
many interviews what what it's going to
look like they need to prepare mentally
and you know technically for the
interviews
um they need to be treated with respect
oh and remember
maybe a year ago or more there was the
threading now that Facebook group so
what behind it uh someone said
what was your worst interview experience
and I was like
gaping when I read it it like had
crazy stories that uh since then
whenever I do like an interviewing
workshops I asked the people that come
to my workshop
did you ever have uh a very bad
interviewing experience and you look
around the room does not usually
the majority of people had like a very
terrible experience whether it was just
that you know no one got mad to them or
or that you know they were treated
unfairly and
um
and a lot of times it's because the
hiring process is not you know lost that
out from the candidate's perspective so
I mean you need to figure out how to
make it affected but only but also how
to make it
uh
respectful because
you would not hire the majority of
candidates that come to your office but
if you do not respond or send the you
know the most basic things
build time
be polite tell people where they are in
the process
that's often neglected
and you know people feel naughty about
it that's just the easy ones like that I
I read some terrible stories there I I
was just really awful stories
um and a lot of times there aren't
enough that I mean the easy the easy
thing is to say there are not enough
resources but basically it's just a
matter of attention yeah you know making
sure that you you prioritize it because
most candidates will not get an offer
and you will not hire them
but they
but they're out there and they might
make a name for you whether you're not
interested yeah and it's a siren glass
though or something right and it's a
small pond it's a very small pond yeah
it's just think clear about you know
what people are you know giving people
that attention works yeah
it's one of the things that have become
that I I had a strong sense of it before
but having gotten to work together these
past few months really solidified is
that you you generally love what you're
doing you really do enjoy it and you can
see it then I think both the we as sort
of the hiring side and the candidates
that everybody feels it and um and now
it's you know it's a simple question of
why you know what is it about what you
do that makes you so enjoy your work
I think
um
it matches my endless curiosity I'm a
very curious person I'm interested in
people so I get to meet lots of people
stay in touch with a lot of people or
more about the world every company that
you know I work with is a world
so that's one aspect it has a lot of
problem solving uh
you know potential right like a lot of
like small things that you need to be
attentive to and figure out then how
and you need to be resourceful working
on it and there's the the hunt right
like there's there's drama there's uh
there's that uh there is building
relationship with wealth of people wow
it's funny sometimes just yesterday
someone came up to me and said to me if
I do remember me and I said I think Mike
my my uh my mind is
too much people like I don't remember
anymore but uh uh but it it's just an
interesting profession
um
because it's very very bright and the
most important thing
I think is it to do a good profession in
my mind because you've helped people
find jobs they're they're thankful to
you yeah rightly your happily
organization but also people like it's
like it's a little bit like being a job
is even um too small to see what it is
it's literally where they're gonna spend
the majority of their diamond yeah and
it's really when it works it's magic
right right I mean we see it here there
literally people here sometimes are
coming
I can definitely see what you're saying
all right I can psych him like it's a
little said like being uh
you know like a doula for a job
really like you know you you make the
right match and it creates value in the
world and people and and when you do it
well it even works even better right
like then everyone went it's a win-win
for everybody right
and uh and I think that what's nice also
is that the alternative sometimes is a
win-lose right and so the default is
what I was hearing is there's sort of
this you know the current the way that
the landscape is is that currently
there's a win-lose situation because
there are these fundamental things that
that that throughout the hiring process
people are lacking yeah and and so we're
already in a way to lose situation and
you're coming in transforming it into a
win-win situation so it's not just
creating value out of nothing it's
taking a negative experience in
transition transmitting it into a fully
high value proposition that's uh and and
I think like when when the person that
you know comes aboard and is not the
right feet comes the board it's terrible
for everyone for maybe they think oh I
wanted that job but eventually like if
it's not the right match then you know
they would probably it probably would
not be great for them either so I
thought they really want to thank you
thank you first for the friendship and
for the support and and for inviting me
again telling us your secrets that
nobody can use in the way then transmit
to win wins and uh and I'm just looking
forward to your dinner working together
thankfully learning from Mr thank you
[Music]